we wanted to let you know here at the
top of today's episode that Journey to
the micro Cosmos is now on Tick Tock you
can think of our tick tocks like the fun
size candy bar of micro Cosmos you will
still find all of your full-length
full-size microcosmos here on YouTube
but if you're looking for a quick little
micro Cosmos snack you can check us out
on Tick Tock where we are at Journey to
the microcosmos
[Music]
foreign
single-celled organisms that we have
seen on our journey through the
microcosmos it would be easy to mistake
this for yet another fascinating spiky
ciliate perhaps something related to a
septorian but with an unusually giant
organelle pulsating within its
boundaries but this is not a
single-celled organism this is an egg
which is also a thrilling site for us
eggs are
incredible whether they are kept within
the confines of their mother or as with
this one released into the world the egg
is all about what comes next within its
confines are cells that divide and
differentiate gathering in numbers while
creating their own individual identities
that will become organs and tissue in
the animal to come and you can see the
animal moving around in its egg restless
and perhaps ready to hatch
and when it does it will take on the
cumulative identity of all of those
cells in this case an animal that we
call the gastro trick
the gastro trick has long been a
personal favorite microbe of several
members of The Journey to the
microcosmos crew they were one of the
first microbes we dedicated an entire
episode 2 and many of us came away
Charmed by their hairy dragon-shaped
bodies but while we were able to see a
lot with the microscopes we had at the
time at James our master of microscopes
has made some significant upgrades since
then thanks in part to the support of
many of you and this means that we are
now able to see gastrotricks in a whole
new light so while before we could see
the hair traveling down the length of
their bodies and even make out the
organs within them now it's like you can
touch them like if you run your finger
along them you will feel the prickle of
scales and the feathery brush of hairs
against your skin and to be honest that
was our main reason for wanting to
revisit them today but while we are here
perhaps we should revisit the gastro
trick more generally if you haven't
watched that first video or just want a
refresher feel free to take a moment to
watch it now we will still be here when
you're done but if you'd rather stick
around the main thing you need to know
is that we titled that episode four day
old grandmothers because for some
gastrotric species reproduction operates
on a very rushed timeline those species
are members of the order chitanada which
sets them in contrast to the other order
of gastrotricks the macrodisuda while
almost all gastro tricks across both
orders can reproduce sexually the
chetanids have an additional approach
orthogenesis this means that they are
able to form an embryo from an
unfertilized egg the reason we're
revisiting the specifics of gastrotric
reproduction is because it might be
related to another fundamental
difference between chetanids and
macroditioids their habitats chetanids
are largely found in French fresh water
while macrodisioids are mostly found in
Marine Waters scientists have long
wondered just how gastro tricks found
themselves in these different
environments it's generally accepted
that the order macrodisiada is older
than the order chatanada that suggests
that gastrotricks began as an order of
marine animals which then went through
some evolutionary pathway that
transitioned some of them to freshwater
life there are many questions that we
could ask about that transition where
did the gastro tricks Journey take them
did this Evolution happen several times
or just once did changes on a geologic
scale like changes in sea level shaped
these long-lasting changes within their
bodies is the Journey of chetanids into
freshwater complete or did any ever
Venture their way back to Marine
environments well when scientists used
the tools of molecular phylogeny they
found evidence that the shift from
Marine to freshwater life happened just
once and it happened fairly quickly and
it may be that parthenogenesis made that
change possible if some of those gastro
tricks in transition had been able to
reproduce via parthenogenesis they may
have had a significant Advantage as they
settled in a new environment without
having to go through the trouble of
fertilization they could have quickly
expanded their population gaining a
foothold allowed them to survive now we
don't know if parthenogenesis did
directly Drive the chetanin's ability to
transition into fresh water but there is
evolutionary precedent for it mud snails
shifted to parthenogenetic reproduction
in their own Marine to freshwater
transition but parthenogenesis is just
one of the traits that might have
allowed these species to spread into
less salty Waters they would have
required other adaptations changes that
would allow them to tolerate the
shifting landscape in the ecology and
geology around them scientists have also
found that there are some Marine gastro
chicks among the otherwise freshwater
chetanids might seem like this
relationship means those Marine gastro
tricks are remnants of the ancient
gastrics who set the stage for
freshwater life but that's not what the
genetics say instead it appears that
these Marine gastro tricks are the
result of chetanids who decided that
freshwater life wasn't for them who
returned to the saltier environments of
their ancestors what drove those gaster
tricks back well aside from the fact
that there was an evolutionary space for
them we don't know animals have been
navigating new environments and finding
ways to adapt for eons each organism
always laying the foundation for new
ways of living building a biology so
complex that even the tiniest bits of it
are worth the sort of intense
unrelenting investigation at humans are
so very very good at
[Music]
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the Unseen World
that surrounds us
the people on the screen right now those
are our patreon patrons they're the
people who make this channel possible
and who allow us to just really unleash
our unrelenting investigation into this
tiny tiny world that so much deserves it
we're really excited to continue that
investigation into 2023 and the reason
we can do it is our patreon patrons so
if you want to add your name to this
list you can go to patreon.com journey
to micro if you want to see more from
our master of microscopes James Weiss
you can check out jam and germs on
Instagram and if you want to see more
from us there is always a subscribe
button somewhere nearby
[Music]
foreign